bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour ce nouveau et binaire donc nous
allons poursuivre cette semaine avec ce
que nous avions commencé la semaine
dernière à propos du british mari la
semaine dernière nous avions abordé
essentiellement
tibial sommellerie comment faire de la
statistiques descriptives avec avec des
tissus mairie cette semaine on va
continuer on va aborder en particulier
qui nous va nous permettre de
représenter des résultats d'un modèle de
régression et puis on verra ensuite des
fonctions plus avancées d'editis mari
comme la fusion de tableau ou encore qu
enfin des statistiques encore plus
personnalisé avec tibial continue aux
eti bilal costume se marie alors je vais
vous afficher en grand mon écran pour
que vous puissiez mieux suivre comme
d'habitude pain si vous le souhaitez
vous pouvez
afficher de me poser vos questions pour
ceux qui sont directs dans le chatt
youtube et pour les autres vous pourrez
toujours comme d'habitude poser vos
questions directement
dans sur le site analyse airs au sol si
des webinaires sur le site analyse r je
vous rappelle sous chacune des pages
vous avez un espace de chat et
discussions et je vous invite d'ailleurs
à poser vos questions sur un analyseur
et de ne pas écrire directement par
email ainsi les réponses que je vous
donnerai pourront profiter à d'autres
alors
on va
et un nouveau script pour la séance
d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est le webinaire numéro 23
ans va sauvegarder notre fichier
comme ça je pourrais vous le script et
puis on va recharger
jti se marient
donc jetty se marie à élan s'est chargé
en mémoire et avant d'aborder la
présentation d'un modèle de régression
va d'abord faire un modèle de régression
donc si vous voulez voir comment faire
une régression logistique un je vous
renvoie au webinaire dédié ainsi
qu'à l'ensemble du chapitre d'analyseurs
consacrer la régression logistique là
j'ai fait une régression rapide donc
toujours à partir du jeu de données de
croire qu'on a utilisé la semaine
dernière donc pour faire une agression
je logistique on va utiliser la fonction
glm
je vais faire un modèle simple qui va
être response une variable de type
binaire où ils n'ont 0,1 et on va faire
grade fringe donc je vais faire un
modèle avec interaction donc grid qui
est une variable catégorielles âge qui
est une variable continu et puis je vais
rajouter une deuxième variable
catégorielles au modèle
date à égal et pour indiquer qu on veut
une régression logistique
on va utiliser family
égale binomiale
et vous avez maintenant du coup un
modèle de régression logistique
si je la fiche rapidement dans la
console vous avez ici le résumé du
modèle alors par défaut on a uniquement
les coefficients
l'interceptent l'équipe fission associés
pour rappel sur un modèle de régression
logistique on veut souvent plutôt
représenté les exponentielle qui sont
des adorations va y revenir et si on
veut afficher un beau tableau de nos
résultats on peut faire appel
directement à tibi donc on prend notre
modèle
cliquetis b elle ouvrit création
alors comme toujours il faut le petit
temps que quelqu'un se fasse
pour que
affiche à l'écran et comme je suis en
plus en train de stream et mon écran ça
met un peu plus de temps mais voyez on a
tout de suite un modèle qui s'affiche
alors
on va déjà voir un sabre davantage leurs
relations tout d'abord
voyez pour la variable comme
précédemment les étiquettes de variables
qui sont stockées avec la belle d' sont
prises en compte de manière prioritaire
on a trois niveaux 1 2 3 vous voyez
qu'on nous a rajouté la modalité de
référence qui fait qu'on la voit tout de
suite dans notre tableau nous avons ici
le déficient leurs intervalles de
confiance et l'épée valeurs qui sont
affichées
tiberi wilson a pu détecter que le
modèle que l'on a fait est une
régression logistique et c'est pour ça
que il a renommé ici les coefficients en
log aux airs de dire le logo rythme des
opérations
et on va voir comment on peut facilement
présenté plus tôt les opérations autre
élément à prendre en compte vous voyez
la distinction variable continu à des
présenté avec un tel coefficient comme
il se doit et puis également
à identifier ici que nous avions une
interaction vous avez étoiles âge donc
le terme d'interaction ici apparaît est
pareil il ya un travail qui est fait sur
la présentation des coefficients puisque
au lieu d'avoir coulé 22.1 âge il va
identifier que c'est la modalité 2° ide
et donc du coup il ya un travail de mise
en forme qui est fait automatiquement
pour celles et ceux qui sont intéressés
qui veulent en savoir plus sachez que
tibet relation fonctionne avec un grand
nombre de modèles les régressions tous
les modèles gel est de manière générale
mais a
alors j'ai vous
afficher sa sueur
ici il faut savoir que
le tibet les règles nationales été
réécrites ya à peu près un nom pour
reposer maintenant sur un package qui
s'appelle blum elle pose donc je vous
emmène sur la page du package powers est
forcément vous verrez que la page est un
leurre marange - point guy du point lieu
puisque je suis le développeur de blum
helpers mais le package est développé
avec daniel jobin qui est le développeur
en fait de jti se marient et vous avez
notamment
sur le site du paquet jornal getting
started
vous avez la liste des modèles qui sont
aujourd'hui couverts donc en fait on a
un grand nombre de modèles notamment des
modèles mixtes de alem 4 vous avez à
voir les modèles multina mios qu'on a
abordé un pour la relégation jeu multi
nominale vous avez aussi les modèles qui
sont faits avec sauvé si vous avez un
modèle avec une régression logistique
avec des données pondérées
et des modèles de survie donc vous avez
un grand nombre de modèles qui sont déjà
couverts naturellement par la brume
helpers et on va voir que brummel peur
ce qui en fait le moteur sous jacent à
tibi elle son mari est en fait qui sert
à 2 package ça sert pour tibéri wilson
et ça sert pour la fonction gg coeff
modèle que je vous représenterait tout à
l'heure
non c'est le package qui est faire tout
le travail de mise en forme et et
présentation des résultats
alors
les dix
premières choses c'est que très souvent
pour une régression logistique ce qu'on
souhaite représenter c'est non pas les
coefficients du modèle mail
exponentielle des coefficients du modèle
puisque dans une régression logistique
ces coefficients vont s'interpréter
comme des opérations d'ailleurs je me
permets de revenir aussi rapidement sur
un analyseur
pour avoir une présentation des
différents types de modèles qui existent
un chapitre que josé rajoute il ya
quelques mois
si vous allez dans
analysé en satisfaire ans et vous verrez
quel type de modèle choisir
et donc dans ce chapitre là qu'on a
abordé rapidement dans le webinaire 21
vous avez en fait la liste de en
fonction de votre variable expliquez
vous avez différents types de modèles et
vous explique comment interpréter
certains coefficient est donc pour la
logistique on va vous dire que les
coefficients en exponentiel sapress
interprète comme des aubes ratios dont
je vais juste que je fais partie
je reviens à tirer l'oreille pour les
jeunes et pour indiquer que ce que je
souhaite c'est à voir plutôt les
exponentielle on peut tout simplement
impliquer la fonction expo
non s'il ya le trou
qui permet de dire que ce que l'on
souhaite afficher ce sont
l'exponentielle les coefficients
et voyez mon tableau s'est mis à jour
avec l'ex potentiel des coefficients les
intervalles de confiance sont également
eux mis à jour et vous voyez que dans
l'en tête ou vous à remplacer
directement avec un horaire et un aux
relations alors comme précédemment là
vous voyez les séparateurs de décimales
sont des points puisqu'on présente par
défaut en anglais
mais comme pour tbilissi maritime peut
tenir compte d'un thème donc si je fais
tu aimes gîte ismaily langage et que je
mets fr
desimone march la virgule et big mac
l'espace
je ris fiche maintenant mon tableau
et vous verrez maintenant une plantation
un petit peu différente et on a
notamment ici des virgules
de même les intervalles de confiance ne
sont plus séparées par une virgule mais
par un tiret
il ya d'autres paramètres sachez que si
par exemple vous avez utilisé le thème
du journal the land 7 et les intervalles
de confiance ont été présentés comme
0.09 tout le monde l'est tout plutôt
qu'un tir est
ici tous ces éléments sont bien sûr
paramétrage
alors premier paramètre important qui le
mêmes paramètres que celui tibill se
marie c'est in cloud qui permet de dire
je souhaite représenter que certains
éléments
donc par exemple je pourrais dire
include maîtres âge
grade si je voulais représenter
uniquement les coefficients
portant sur age dégrade donc on n'est
pas obligés de représenter un modèle en
entier voyez qu'ici je n'ai pas
l'interaction entre grade et agen qui du
coup a est séparé
si je veux l'unc l'urgent c'est crade
âge mais je suis même pas sûr
dans ces grades 2 points agen voyez donc
si je veux mettre le tehrik le terme
d'interaction c'est possible mais il
faut je le précise manuellement
hier de dire que je veux aussi
représenté le terme d'interaction c'est
que vous avez un sélecteur qui s'appelle
hall internation
comme on avait vu au le conti news et
qui permet de sélectionner uniquement
les termes d'interactions
voyez que ici j'ai bien grade âge et
l'interaction qui nous est présenté
alors le include 1 il est utile que dans
certains cas où on va avoir besoin vous
avez un modèle je sais pas mais avec une
quinzaine de variables il n'a que deux
ou trois qui vous intéressent sinon
n'hésitez pas à
indiquer
comme pour tibial se marie il vous est
possible de changer une étiquette avec
la belle donc comme précédemment comme
on l'a vu c'est pour le paramètre label
c'est une formule où une liste de
formule donc là par exemple je vais
changer le label unique encourage donc à
schild et je vais dire
en année
ça va me permettre de changer
l'étiquette de la variable âge
vous verrez que serait un impact ici à
la fois pour âge en année et puis grade
et âge j'ai aussi la possibilité de
changer que l'étiquette de l'interaction
puisque l'interaction envoyé par défaut
elle utilise en fait un mélange d
des étiquettes existantes mais
normalement si je fais les grades h deux
points qui est notre terme d'interaction
je peux mettre
interactions une étiquette qui lui
serait propre
entre
grade et âge
alors je
si souci l'allier un petit peu parce que
pour a gémi n'a changé bon j'ai regardé
ça c'est une nouveauté
sur la sélection de variables on va
écouter désolé
j'ai vérifié où ça va
alors dans autre paramètre
vous avez
un paramètre
toute simple qui suit est ce qu'on veut
voir l'interceptent parce que parfois on
a besoin que de deux l'interceptent
elle a un vous avez aussi intercepte
égal tout vous pouvez passer et pour
dire que vous souhaitez également
affiché l'interceptent alors pour rappel
dans une régression logistique
l'interceptent c'est ce qui va
déterminer la probabilité
d'un individu à l'ensemble des modalités
de référence en fait on applique le 0,14
à 0 5% ont donc
soit si vous savez manier l'interceptent
ce n'hésitez pas à l'affiché si vous
avez des doutes ne la plupart du temps
on peut se passer de présenter
l'interceptent dans nos résultats de
deux modèles un tout dépend de ce que
l'on dit ce que l'on veut faire
comme précédemment on peut on peut
vouloir éventuellement aussi vouloir
changer l'intitulé de certaines des
colonnes qui nous sont présentés alors
je vous rappelle on peut stocker le
résultat dans un objet
tibi elle et puis pour modifier des
intitulés colonnes on passe par la
fonction modified heures mais on a
besoin de savoir quels sont le nom des
colonnes à faire et donc on l'avait vu
la semaine dernière nous avons la
fonction show is earl hines à qui je
peux passer un tableau qui va m'indiquer
le nom des différents des différentes
colonnes donc là on voit que c'est ce
que le mien s'appelle label la seconde
s'appelle estimate la troisième
s'appelle cio et la dernière s'appelle
paix point value donc si je veut
modifier l'intitulé ici je pourrais
simplement faire
tbr
modify
et d'un effet rob dette
et donc là j'avais un ticket avec une
fonction où une liste de avec une
formule une liste de formules par
exemple estimate
side
les doubler rappel c'est pour afficher
du gras
et voiliers j'ai mis à jour alors il m'a
conserver du coup la traduction que aux
ratios vous dira ports de côte en
français je pourrais supprimer ma note
si je le voulais en appliquant modify
footnote et a estimé je vais m elle a
pour dire je ne veux pas de notes pour
cette colonne
et pourquoi je ne l'est pas
normalement j'aurais dû me supprime
hélène je recommence
j'ai dû me tromper quelque part sur la
note de bas de page à chaque fois je me
fais avoir ben haim n'affiche quand même
voyons voir sur modify
footnote
alors
yacine après suit en fait
là c'est l'abréviation en fait qui est
associé à une note complète c'est juste
une abréviation donc il faut que
j'ajoute après vias
pour dire c'est l'abréviation que je
modifie
mais voilà donc il ya deux notes de bas
de page dans les notes génériques et
puis les notes qui sont associés à une
abréviation donc là en fête est celle
qui est asocial révélation il me fallait
changer ici
alors une question qui nous est posée
c'est est ce qu'on peut modifier le
seuil pour l'intérêt de confiance alors
effectivement par défaut nous avons des
intervalles de confiance qui sont
présentés à
qui sont d intervalle de confiance
à 95 % mais je peux appliquer et ibm
sun on va garder notre exponentielle
égale cloud est normalement c'est qu'on
point le vel cij indique
0.9 c'est à dire 90 %
on va vérifier que j'ai bien en mémoire
le nom du paramètre exactement c'est 90%
alors vous n'avez pas besoin de
connaître tous les le tous les
paramètres parker un vous pouvez aussi
tout simplement
regarder l'aide de la fonction comme
vous avez un doute pour retrouver mais
effectivement on a confié le vel qui
permet aussi de spécifier le paramètre
le niveau de confiance des intervalles
de confiance
lorsqu'il pleut intéressant c'est
d'ajouter des étoiles de significativité
à notre tableau et ça on peut le faire à
avec la fonction
j'apprenne d'autres termes
au genre partie mode
tibial pour les coulisses exponentielle
du cloud cloud donc là vous avez nos
tableaux de base et puis vous savez
parfois on voit dans certaines revues ou
dans certains journaux une présentation
de nos
[Musique]
ddb valeur avec des petites étoiles 1
qui indique si jamais les résultats sont
significatifs alors ça ça peut se faire
avec la fonction had signification
star
on y voit le résultat qui nous indique
sauf que là on a rien qui est
significatif
si jamais nos résultats sont
significatifs et des étoiles qui sont
par défaut une étoile cip est inférieure
à 5 % 2 étoiles cip est inférieur à 1 %
et 3 étoiles six pays est inférieure à
1% alors juste une petite précision il
ya par défaut ça va masquer les paies
valeurs et les intervalles de confiance
et ça nous affiche par contre l'écart
type jusque là on n'affichait pas on
peut
contrôler saint vous avez ici eide
c'est
égal fall pour des je ne veux je veux
garder mais intervalles mais deux je
veux garder miss intervalle de confiance
hype égal face
je veux continuer d'afficher
l'épée valeur en plus des étoiles et
a aidé ce pour dire je veux masqué à
l'écart type c'est juste de différente
manière d'afficher les éléments je vais
vous afficher rapidement l'aide de la
fonction
pour avoir une
a rendu alors
quelques éléments c'est vous avez les
étoiles en fait elles sont elles sont
rajoutés si vous voyez des exemples qui
sont fournis elles sont rajoutés ici
dans la colonne estimate qui par défaut
vos bêta qui nous vaut aux ratios parce
que c'est un intervalle de confiance on
voyait elles sont rajoutés ici donc
c'est à dire que si l'on nous avions eu
des résultats significatifs
on l'aurait eue dans la colonne aux
rations quand ça se sera ajouté à cet
endroit là
voyez un exemple là
il est possible de paramétrer les
niveaux de coupure pour les étoiles le
par défaut c'est trois étoiles en
dessous de 1 pour 1000 2 en dessous de
1% et une autre où 2 5% qui est vraiment
l'affichage le plus courant mais vous
pouvez paramétrer et voyez ces
fonctions-là qui permettent de changer
le rendu affichée et tout comme ici qui
permettent de changer la manière de
représenter nos résultats
alors un autre effet qui est peut-être
plus intéressant
pour nous
c'est la question des variables
dichotomique alors je vais refaire un
tableau
et donc parfois des variables qui nous
que deux modalités par exemple ici la
variable trt qui s'affichent comme
chemotherapy in treatment c'est une
variable dichotomique une variable
binaire est donc en fait quand on a une
variable à une seule catégorie là de
modalités on n'a qu'un seul coefficient
puisque c'est forcément ce coefficient
la versus
le coefficient de base alors que quand
on a trois modalités
quand on fait des contrastes au
classique je vous ferai un jour peut
être je pense à un webinaire sur les
contrastes mais on compare par défaut un
à la motilité d'affaires souvent
d'intérêt a présenté les 3 mais là on
pourrait dire mais au lieu d'avoir trois
lignes une avec chemotherapy treatment
c'est une drogue à et une jacques b on
pourrait mettre je suis finalement juste
une ligne 1 puisque on a juste besoin du
0,13 tout comme pour la variable âge
mais qui a qu'un seul confie science est
une agréable continue on a affiché qu'un
seul donc on peut utiliser la fonction
moins l'argument qui s'appelle chose
single run
pour indiquer démaria bhl d'inr il faut
que ça soit une variable in her qu'on
indique que l'on souhaite afficher sur
une seule ligne
donc là
je viens
rt
il voyait
une seule ligne j'aurais pu aussi dire
aux rôles dicko tonus normalement ça
marche aussi pour dire toutes les
variables binaire les affiches sur une
seule ligne
ce qui me fait que j'ai pas rejoindre
les alors dans le cas présent on voit
quand même que on aurait intérêt à
représenter un petit peu mieux parce que
chemotherapy tweets n'étaient pas
forcément explicite dans ce gala dans ce
cas là j'aurais intérêt à changer qui
aiment le label pur trt pour en faire
quelque chose de plus simple par exemple
traitement des versus traitement
à ça me permet de raccourcir mon tableau
et en même temps de présenter un item
qui sera
qui sera compréhensible
en tant que ça 1 ça met toujours un
petit peu de temps
pendant ce temps là ça me permet de
rappeler que les tableaux qu'on obtient
sont les tableaux que j'ai qui se
marient comme les autres et donc on peut
tout à fait avoir recours à des
fonctions comme bolt
label
attendez je crois que
je pense que air studio vient de planter
je monte de patienter un petit peu
c'est de redémarrer
donc je vais recharger
kitty se marie on t'aime mon modèle
et je vous
tableau
1 donc
le label j'ai modifié pour contre
quelque chose de plus lisible ici et
puis ball label singes utilisés pour que
les noms de variables soient mis en gras
et donc du coup soit plus lisible mais
on avait aussi eu j'aurais aussi pu
utiliser ita lives
label ce
pour mettre les noms de variables en
italique en alternative
alors pour mettre en forme les
coefficients on avait vu le parable
d'antibes ihealth au meurice et est le
paramètre dj ce qui permettait
d'indiquer le nombre de décimales que
l'on voulait afficher et entremont vous
pouvez lui passer une fonction pour
mettre en forme les coefficients
r c'est possible de mettre en forme les
éléments
alors on a en fait deux paramètres un
qui s'appelle estime est fun qui est une
fonction pour mettre en forme à l'est
les coefficients et qui sera aussi
utilisé du coup pour les intervalles de
confiance et puis un autre paramètre qui
es
tu es value funky une fonction pour
mettre en forme les faits valeur il faut
savoir que dans citi se marie par défaut
l'épée valeurs sont mis en forme d'une
certaine manière dans le sens où au
dessus de 20 c'est la fonction styles
p value qui est utilisée est une des
particularités de cette fonction là je
vous montre un exemple on va
c'est que on arrondit en fonction des
valeurs c'est à dire que tout ce qui est
au dessus de 90 %
s'arrondit à supérieur à 0,9
tout ce qui est ensuite toutes les
autres valeurs sont arrondis à un seul
une seule décimales est en dessous de 1%
on arrondit à deux décimales
puis
quand ça descend un peu plus bas on
arrondit à trois décimales est en
dessous de 1 pour 1000 on affiche
simplement inférieure à un pour mille
non c'est une manière en fait de
de n'afficher finalement que des
chiffres signifiant mais on pourrait
tout à fait présenter autrement alors
là je vais faire un tableau
par exemple on avait vu hier les
fonctions de skype qui permettent de
faire des mises en forme je faire estime
être
fun
donc un jeu
fonctions pour mettre en forme
les coefficients donc je vais faire
appel à ce qu'à la belle amber skelos
l'appel number et là je vais dire que je
veux un arrondi
avec trois chiffres
et puis p value fans
je petit aussi alors il ya une fonction
dans qui est la belle plus value
et je vais dire que
les on va aussi mettre trois chiffres
après la virgule et on peut rajouter
l'outil à 2 p égal choo pour rajouter
une paix valeur devant et si je fais ça
je vais pouvoir afficher
mon tableau
avec une mise en forme un peu différente
notez que les fonctions de ce qu'ils ne
prennent pas en compte le paramètre
génériques sur le décimales marque qu'on
a fait dans le thème au tout début donc
si je veux utiliser la vie recul je dois
rajouter pour ma part manuellement ici à
mon code
1-1 décimales marque
utiliser les fonctions à
style de jets et se marie à
vous
[Musique]
vous aurez la prise en compte de ce
paramètre là mais ce qui se passe c'est
que ces fonctions mais en fait il faut
les appeler en créant une fonction de la
baule et donc si j'avais voulu faire la
même chose avec les fonctions de gengis
mari je vous montre le code
correspondant
par exemple pour utiliser style sic fig
ok la fonction
de base
2 nombre à la difficulté c'est que je ne
peux pas l'appeler directement parce que
elle me renvoie quelque chose de mignon
en forme et pas la fonction donc
ce que je peux faire c'est créer une
fonction à la volée
fonctionne x qui va appeler style
cycliques 2x dj tu égal 3 est ici
j'aurai quelque chose d'à peu près
équivalent en disant
je crée une fonction à la volée
en l'appelant style
d'eva lyon
mais voyez ce qui se passe et que estime
et fun et paix value fun
attendent de recevoir une fonction hors
style cycling ne renvoie pas une
fonction c'est une fonction qui met en
forme à la différence de ce créances à
l'aller les fonctions label de skies
elle vous renvoie systématiquement des
fonctions normalement
il ya une syntaxe
à la taille d'hiver ce qui est autorisé
ici qui consiste en fait à écrire la
fonction sous forme d'une formule
est donc dans ce cas vous devez
commencer par un petit lde
est votre premier paramètre s'appelle
point x alors je montre
mes
avant c'est donc si vous avez un doute
ou si vous la comprenez pas bien
il n'a pas forcément besoin de de la
retenir ah mais ça permet en fait de
définir des fonctions un peu à la volée
et puis normalement je crois qu'il ya
une dernière option
non c'est en 20 sec piot par avance
ça arrive régulièrement fait qu'on a
besoin d'utiliser une fonction a en fait
on veut créer une fonction qui est une
autre fonction avec juste certains
paramètres par défaut qu'on aura changé
persyn avec la fonction par chiale de
pew l'idée c'est de dire on préremplie
un peu certains paramètres de la
fonction alors je vous remets je vous
réglez la même chose que la toute
conscience qu'on a fait d'accord donc
mode
si bielles en régression
et donc estime est fun c'est pour dire
moi ce que je veux c'est utiliser style
sic fig
mais je peux encore pré remplir le vide
juste prêt à remplir le dj segal 3 donc
dans ce cas là il faut aller chercher
la fonction partial
de piau je commence par lui indiquer la
fonction qui m'intéressent qui l'a
est-il sic figues et je vais juste pré
remplir certains arguments
et en fait ça va ça va me gêner en fait
partielles va générer une fonction qui
appelle stick figues avec dj de cigales
et je peux faire pareil du coup
pour p value
fun
avec ici styles p valliot
donc ce qu'il faut
piot par un chien permet en fait de
renvoyer une
fonction en fait on génère une foule à
la volée une fonction qui correspond à
une autre fonction qu'on a indiqué avec
certains paramètres par défaut qu'on
aura passé
d'envoyer tout ça c'est quatre manières
différentes d'arriver à peu près au même
résultat
alors un autre élément qui peut être
intéressant quand on
[Musique]
présente notre modèle
c'est d'afficher les coefficients pour
les modalités de référence ce qui peut
se faire avec had
estimate
tous
vos références
blues égale trou alors je vous montre le
résultat
dans
vous voyez ça m'a remplacé en fait le
tir et pour les monnaies de référence
par la valeur 1.0 puisque
l'aude ratio pour milliers de références
elle est de 1.0 dans le cas du type de
contrat ce qu'on utilise ici le jour où
je vous ferai un cours sur les autres
formes de contrats sont vayrac si un
intérêt un peu particulier voilà mais
c'est juste une manière de rappeler un
la valeur du coefficient ya pas de paix
valeur il n'ya pas d'internât de
confiance à 95 % parce que ça ne fait
pas sens donc à présent mais ça permet
juste d'afficher ce 1.0
ce qui peut être intéressant
on l'avait abordée dans le cadre du
cours sur la régulation logistique au
delà des paies valeur pour chacune des
modalités chacun des coefficients donc
pour rappel l'épée valeur ici indique si
l'aude ratio présenté ici est
statistiquement différents 2
062 un pardon si un ancien le saboter
différentes 0 et donc on a un
coefficient pour on a une telle valeur
pour chacun à chacun des coefficients
mais parfois ce que l'on aimerait c'est
avoir une paix valeur globale pour les
pour les variables
ce qui peut se faire
avec
atteint globale qui
donc
fête à global pis on va calculer à la
volée avec une à nova les valeurs
globales pour chacune les des valeurs
globales pour chacune des variables ce
qui permet de dire est ce que wade de
manière générale un effet je regarde pas
si certains coefficients sont
significatifs je regarde les faits
globale de la variable pour une variable
continu comme agen ça change pas du tout
la valeur globale pareil pour qu'il
obtienne le petit tweet par défaut
lorsque
[Musique]
lorsque l'on affiche les algues global
pis les valeurs les valeurs globales
ça masque les valeurs individuelles mais
on peut conserver c'est pas la valeur
individuelle avec une option 1 qui
équipent
égal ou
qui permet d'afficher
les deux types
2 p valeur
donc là vous
la fois l'épée valeur globale affiché
sur l'ondé variable et l'épée valeur de
chacun des coefficients sachant que pour
la variable âge ça ne change pas puisque
c'est une variable continu pour rappel
si vous voulez plus d'information sur
les pets valeur globale je vous invite à
revenir sur l'analyseur est allé sur le
chapitre régression logistique binaire
où on répond
ray aborde cette question des valeurs
globales et plus spécifiquement on
aborde aussi les différents types
parce qu'il ya trois types de tests que
l'on peut faire avec une à nova pour
calculer dp valeur globale
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que tant que
vous n'avez pas d'interaction dans un
modèle a besoin de s'occuper et quand
vous avez des interactions il est
conseillé d'avoir plutôt recours au type
d'accord mais normalement le calcul du
type 3 à certaines règles et donc
certains préféraient utiliser le type de
ce que je veux ça c'est vraiment pour
les utilisateurs avancés mais retenez
que par défaut ça vous et affichez un
seul type iii qui calculait est en fait
vous avez dans art global
si vous regardez les lettres de a global
paix pour une régression
vous avez la possibilité
d'un paramètre type qui peut qui est un
deux ou trois pour préciser ce que l'on
veut utiliser mais à usage la plupart
d'entre vous on n'aura pas besoin
alors
avant de continuer je vais revenir sur
une question qui est posée
je n'ai pas bien compris à quoi
correspondent les arguments style sic
fille gothique dévalue il désigne la
fonction par défaut dont on modifie
simplement les dj alors je vais
reprendre ce petit point là mais qui est
le petit point avant c'est
donc pour comprendre estime est fan a
besoin de recevoir une fonction
d'accords et donc une fonction qui prend
à qui on passe des valeurs et qui les
met en forme
ce qu'est la belle numbers toutes les
fonctions label du paramètre du package
ce qui est leur envoie des fonctions
donc supposons que je stocke le résultat
de ça dans f d'accord
l'objet f qui renvoyait par
qui remplacer par spears label numbers
est une fonction d'accords et donc je
peux donc faire rêve de 2.5 ça va me le
mettre en forme
donc la belle numbers est une fonction
qui renvoie une fonction
maintenant style sic fig c'est une
fonction qui met en forme
d'accord et donc
si je tape c'est cyclique x en fait ce
qui l'attend
ccm donc qu'ils soient passés là je
pourrais passer de 2,5 là il met très en
forme de virgule ce1 m'est-il cycliques
et c'est une fonction qui mes enfants et
moi ce que je veux faire c'est une
fonction qui applique style sic figues
avec dj de seagal 3
une première manière de faire ça c'est
je crée ma propre fonction donc fonction
x je crée une fonction qui prend x en
entrée et qui renvoie steal things fig 2
x avec l'option des cheats égal 3
donc en fait j'ai écrit une fonction à
la volée
une autre possibilité d'écrire ça pour
écrire une fonction à la volée c'est de
l'écrire dans ce style là c'est à dire
une formule avec un style stylistique
fait point x budget égal 3 alors ça
c'est une manière d'écrire plus
rapidement ceux ci
et ça c'est une syntaxe un peu
particulière qui a introduite par
certaines fonctions du tailles diverses
si vous la comprenez pas voulu oublier
un retenez ça qui est vraiment là
certains génériques pour écrire une
fonction et puis une autre manière c'est
d'appeler pew marcheurs d'accord donc la
fonction partial de pure elle prenne
fonction en entrée
elle renvoie une fonction en fait ce que
fait quand j'écris ceci avec pure
partial dj segal 3 c'est la même chose
quasiment que d'écrire ceci en fait ça
me renvoie la fonction style sic fig
mais en lui passant qui dit segal 3 ce
qui fait que ce que me renvoi pur
partial le stocker le résultat dans un
objet f
ça me renvoie une fonction
s'armeront voit une fonction on a pré
remplie ddte avec 3 ce qui fait que si
je fais un rêve de 2.5 jeux gais
donc c'est eux
c'est ce et du coup ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que tout ça ce sont
différentes manières différentes de
réécrire à la volée une fonction qui
utilisent ne touche
donc quand vous avez un doute surtout
vous hésitez pas à les regarder les
exemples et puis surtout si vous avez un
doute sur jusqu'en mettre en forme vous
retournez sur un analyseur vous avez
le schapi tableaux statistiques avancées
avec kitty se marie
là vous
pour les modèles avec tiberi sean pour
modifier les coefficients et là vous
avez directement des exemples qui vous
sont donnés
ou alors vous retournez voir le
webinaire pour retrouver la syntaxe par
la suite
lorsque l'on a vis le
lait dans un précédent au webinaire nous
avions apporté le problème de la multi
co linéarité dans la régression donc je
vais pas revenir plus avant sur ce
problème là
est
la question est donc sur la question de
la multi colline hérité
dans le chapitre qui consacre et on l'a
abordée dans webinaire numéro 07 on a un
indicateur qui sont les villes où les
facteurs d'inflation de la variance à
et donc du coup on va vérifier qu'on a
des vivres qui sont pas trop élevés
d'accord il existe neuf se calculer
directement avec duty se marie 1 on va
dans ce cas là fernand tiberi guen
et rajoute
on a deviné
qui permet de rajouter une colonne avec
le vif alors plus précisément vous avez
un commando des variables avec intel
catégorielles vous avez un vif
généralisée et sa version ajustée encore
une fois je vous renvoie à l'autre cours
dédiés au vif sur leur interprétation
alors
je vous l'avais dit y a
quand on fait un tableau de régression
on peut aussi directement en faire un
graphique en lui appliquant pelote si
j'applique pelote à un objet tibet
régulation j'obtiens directement un
tableau des coefficients du modèle est
en fait ce tabloïd est réalisé avec gégé
coeff
mais du coup ça retient certains
paramètres par exemple si on la fait
exponentielle est égal chew 1 dans le
tibia régulation ça va être transmis
comme paramètre à gg coeff
modèle
si vous voulez malgré tout avoir plus
d'éléments de mise en forme je vous
invite plutôt à appliquer vous même gg
coeff meneur qui pour rappel 1 et dans
le package et gally
et vous pouvez du coup appliquée gg
coeff modèle
qui a des options où vous aurez plus
d'options de mise en forme pour votre
tableau ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
de toute façon les deux à les deux
fonctions j'ai quand même modèle les
pythies berrichonne reposent toutes les
deux sur blue album helpers il se trouve
que ggf modèle c'est moi qui les
développer et donc voilà donc c'est la
fonction claude qu'on applique un
objectif de progression c'est juste une
manière rapide
ici
alors je voilà dans le chat qu'il ya des
questions qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
question à que le webinaire du jour je
suis désolé je n'y répondrai pas pendant
le webinaire par contre vous pouvez les
poser vos questions dont les espaces de
discussion du chapitre correspondant sur
un analyseur je vous le rappelle sur
analyseur
vous avez un espace de commentaire tout
en bas et donc pouvait si jamais ça
correspond bien au chapitre en cours y
poser vos questions je précise si vous
mourriez des questions par email je n'y
répondrai pas j'en reçois beaucoup je ne
peux pas malheureusement répondre à tout
le monde quand c'est dans les
commentaires j'essaye d'y répondre parce
que du coup il ya une trace et que ça
profite à d'autres mais sinon voila je
je je je suis trop sollicités pour
permettre de répondre à toutes les
sollicitations individuel
sur un modèle vous avez également des
statistiques globales qui peuvent être
calculés lors les différentes
statistiques globales qui existe dans un
modèle dépendent du type de modèle mais
elles peuvent être obtenus avec la
fonction glance de broome alors pour
rappel dans boom il ya deux fonctions
importantes la fonction tidy qui vous
fait un
vouloir montrer qu'on l'a déjà abordé
mais qui vous fait en fait un tableau de
données avec les principaux résultats
d'ailleurs ce que l'on fait pour nos
tableaux c'est qu'on passe par brahim
saïdi et ensuite broom helpers améliore
le résultat de brunt heidi puisque vous
avez un
dans le package regroupant elles peur ce
qu'on va appeler une fonction taille
d'hypnose klaus qui repart en fait des
résultats de broome et qui va les mettre
en forme pour ajouter des étiquettes le
type de variables
les modalités de référence
mais ce qui nous intéresse c'est que
groom fonctionne offre aussi une
fonction gland ce donc lens qui marche
aura grand nombre de modèles différents
en fait ça renvoie un tableau vous
l'avez ici avec des statistiques
générales du modèle les statistiques
dépend du type de modèle là en
l'occurrence pour notre régression
logistique nous avons notamment la
vraisemblance houlot glick
l'aïs c'est qu'on a déjà abordé le pays
c'est le nom de le nombre de degrés de
liberté des résidus encore le nombre
d'observations
et il est possible alors je vais pas
revenir sur toutes ces sept dépend de
chacun des modèles
mais on peut les rajouter à notre
tableau
donc de deux manières différentes j'ai
prendre tbl wilson et je peux rajouter
had lens thébaux
qui va rajouter
à la fin de mon tableau est ici j'ai
vous voyez les variables et ensuite vous
avez les différents paramètres qui sont
rajoutés automatiquement si je veux pas
tout mettre je peux dans ce qu'elle a
indiqué ce que je veux rajouter avec le
paramètre include
et je vais indiquer une liste de
paramètres a affiché par exemple ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la i c est le nombre
d'observations
et donc ce que je
en fait les en têtes des colonnes qui
sont là retenez que jeu suivant type de
modèle vous avez vous fait un modèle je
sais pas moi un modèle mixte vous aurez
d'autres indicateurs vous auriez un
modèle linéaire vous enviez certains
indicateurs comme le m² donc les les
indicateurs que l'on peut afficher c'est
sûr que l'on obtient avec lens est
plutôt que de l'affiché en bas du
tableau donc avec des lignes
supplémentaires vous avez aussi la
possibilité
de les intégrer en fait en tant que
source note
et donc si vous faites ça sa valeur
ajoutée dans les notes du tableau et non
pas au tableau donc on a ces indicateurs
de manière plus discrète tout en bas du
tableau
alors je vous donne deux minutes
rapidement pour me dire s'il vous reste
des questions sur tibial régulation
avant on passe à l'étape d'après
donc aujourd'hui un j'aborde pas les
enjeux de comment on fait la régression
ou les résultats du modèle pour ça je
vous renvoie encore une fois au chapitre
dédié sur analysait ray pied au
webinaire que l'on a déjà fait là ce que
le joue sous montrer c'est que l'on peut
rapidement faire un tableau propre
quasiment publiables tel quel dans une
revue
alors je
question que je veux garder pour plus
tard qui porte sur l'exportation dans
excel je reviendrai tout à l'heure sur
les exports de tableau donc c'est prévu
mais ça arrivera un peu plus tard dans
la session du jour
ce que je vous propose de voir c'est
comment est-ce qu'on peut combiner des
tableaux
alors on va faire
on va pour cela faire deux petits
tableaux donc on va voir comment
combiner
des tableaux donc pour ça j'ai écrit
deux tableaux on va faire 2 à 2 2
modèles jeune tafer donc je vais faire
un glm un
responsable des rt donc un modèle
logistique avec uniquement des faits de
traitement sur réponse à partir de
nettoyage et family
égale
binomiale
je fais mon modèle et je veux en faire
un tableau de régression
et jeu un deuxième tableau je vais
copier coller un pour gagner un peu de
temps et je vais rajouter du coup
grade plus
marqueur
est plus sage
donc là j'ai fait deux tableaux d'accord
a alors on va peut-être les passer en
exponentiel trop ce sera un peu plus
propre
exponentielle égal ou
g de tableau si je vous affiche le
tableau 1 à l'écran un c'est uniquement
là un modèle avec une seule variable
donc j'ai l'effet de la variable
traitement
[Musique]
ce qu'on voudrait faire ça serait
pouvoir les mettre les uns au-dessus des
autres donc premier quart de
de fusion de tableau on va coller les
tableaux l'un au dessus de l'autre donc
on parle de stack en anglais tous taxés
les maîtres les ans tu disais c'est
empilés et on a une fonction qui
s'appelle tbl stack le principe de tvs
taxe et qu'elle va recevoir une liste
de tableau donc je crée liste et je vais
faire listes et un t2
et donc tableau et on va les mettre l'un
au dessus de l'autre
tel quel ce qui est un petit peu
embêtant c'est que on comprends pas trop
que en fait il ya un premier tableau
puis un deuxième parce que chemotherapy
de suite mes tarifs deux fois et donc on
peut avoir intérêt à faire des en têtes
pour bien distinguer les deux tableaux
avec groupe leader donc là je vais
donner des noms différents et je veux
dire j'ai un modèle dit variés
puis j'ai un modèle multivariée
le premier bizarrerie puisqu'il a qu'une
seule variable
donc là un g la la c'est cette mise en
forme est-ce que je peux mettre du graff
je vais réussir rapidement à ce qu'on
peut mettre du cra cette étape
j'ai un doute non il le prend pas
donc là je
tableau l'un au dessus de l'autre une
autre manière de recouper mes tableaux
plutôt que de les mettre l'un au dessus
de l'autre
je vais peut-être ici mettre des
majuscules pour mieux voir un modèle
peut varier
un plutôt que
au dessus de l'autre on pourra avoir
envie de les coller de l'un à côté de
l'autre et de partir du coup plutôt sur
une fusion gauche droite et ça ça se
fait avec la fonction tbl merde vous
voyez c'est à peu près la même chose tu
es belle merde c'est juste que je lui
passe aussi une liste de tableau
sauf que ça va m tableau l'un à côté de
l'autre autre élément important avec
tibet de merde faut penser un peu comme
vous tableau vous savez quand on fait un
airbag pour coller des étiquettes ou
mersch quand on veut coller les colonnes
c'est que tes billets le maire je fais
attention à bien aligner les variables
entre elles
là dans notre tableau trt est en
troisième position mais comme mon ami
d'abord le premier tableau a été arrêté
en premier bien arrêté a été remonté et
la fusion s'est bien fait avec les
bonnes variable variable pas variable la
fusion s'est faite pour est fait
correctement
et on peut
présenter un petit peu mieux en tout cas
donné les étiquettes ont plutôt que voir
tableau un tableau 2e avec tab span
heure est donc là je l'indiquais modèle
bi variés
et
modèle multi marié
alors je vous prie
finalement et après je répondrai à la
question de l'arsenal où
tu es belle strates a alors l'idée de tb
strata c'est que ça permet de calculer
des tableaux pour chaque sous-ensembles
définie par une variable catégorielles
et ensuite de les fusionner ensemble
alors on va faire un exemple
supposons
je vais prendre je vais créer un
sous-ensemble d'accord donc ggfr tmp 1
je vais partir de thorium
je vais retenir certaines variables il
me faut un select sauf que j'ai pas
charger taille diverse en mémoire donc
on va les charges et le tec l'hiver sans
mémoire
toujours pratique
donc je vais faire select j'ai gardé que
certaines variables pourraient alléger
un peu les choses dont je vais prendre
âge
grade
stage et terreau t
il puisque je vais faire je vais un tout
petit peu renommée je vous montre
comment à quoi ressemble à 20 3 yards
grade
elle est cotée en 1 2 3 est ce que je
vais faire en fait je vais en faire
quelque chose ou ce qui va
donc je vais monter mp et je vais juste
revoir mes niveaux l'éleveuse de tmp
walid je vais les renommer en
rite 1
pourquoi je le fais juste après c'est
pourquoi quelque chose de plus lisible
alors l'idée c'est que je vais prendre
mon jeu de nouveaux jeux de données la
tmp
je vais appeler tb strata et l'idée
c'est que j'aimerais faire un
[Musique]
un tableau
descriptif
en fonction traitement pour chacun des
grades
j'aimerais appliquée tibi elles se
marient by traitement pour chacune des
valeurs de grade
ça se fait en indiquant qu'elle est la
variable qui va servir de strates donc
ici c'est grave
et il faut que j'aie indique qu'elle est
la tb le fun c'est pour indiquer quelle
va être la fonction que je veux utiliser
pour créer mais sous tableau
alors la syntaxe elle se fait avec le
tibet le point qu'on avait vu tout à
l'heure
vous avez pas besoin de tout retenir il
faut justement retrouver en fait les
exemples donc en fait ça prends mon jeu
mon jeu de données et j'ai appliqué tibi
elle
se marie
by tiers t
missing égale nos pour alléger mon
tableau et là dessus
on va appliquer à athènes
donc en fait là je donne une fonction
qui va calculer pour chaque
sous-ensemble de grade un tableau et je
veux les fusionner je vous montre le
résultat
alors ça m'a un petit peu tendre calcul
vous voyez ça m'a fait un tableau
alors avec grade 1 gramme de gras 3g
renommée en fait parce que sinon
j'aurais eu que 1 2 ou 3 et c'est plus
explicites comme ça et pour chacun j'ai
bien le sou tableau on obtient faisant
tibial se marient donc ça permet de
faire plusieurs types et elle se marie à
la volée et vous avez aussi la
possibilité de demander à ce que le
tableau soit les uns sur les autres et
pas les uns à côté des autres et vous
avez une un argument combine weave on
peut dire tibet le stack plutôt petit
billet le merde donc sachez juste que ça
existe un là on est sur des choses déjà
un petit peu plus avancée mais ça peut
être ça peut être pratique à l'occasion
et je vais aborder maintenant une
question qui est posée par arsène
permet de faire une analyse by varier en
fonction de certaines variables alors
une analyse variés on sait quand on fait
un modèle avec une seule variable
techniquement le tableau t1 c'est une
analyse by variés alors on dit unis ou
bi variés tout dépend des auteurs mais
univariée parce que l'art est une
variable explicative hobby variés parce
qu'on a mis deux variables ensemble
là pour le coup on regarde les faits de
jack à 12 - du traitement indépendamment
des autres variables et c'est vrai qu'il
est assez fréquent dans certaines
analyses de faire les analyses vivarié
de chacune des variables explicatives
avant de faire
une analyse multivariée avec toutes les
variables donc ce qu'on veut faire ce
sont des analyse univariée répétées et
ça peut se faire avec tvl
uv régulation alors
l'idée on va refaire en fait à chaque
fois des modèles alors
pour utiliser tbl
uv régression sa sa taxe elle est un
petit peu
un peu plus compliquer déjà on va on va
faire un jeu de données et au lieu de
passer de file en entier on va passer
que les variables qui nous intéresse
j'ai déjà
ralentir donc là ce qu'on va vouloir
c'est on va faire des modèles sur aube
response et on veut voir les effets de
hache gratter stage j'ai gardé que les
variables dont j'ai besoin
et je vais appeler tbl uv régression
on va indiquer quelle est la méthode
qu'on utilise c'est à dire quelle
fonction va utiliser pour faire la
régression en l'occurrence nous à faire
des
responsables oui/non donc on va faire
des régression logistique binaire on va
passer par gl m d'accord mais dans
d'autres cas de figure sont intégrés
agression linéaire on passerait par la
fonction elle aime qu'on fait là ce
qu'on nous demande c'est d'indiquer la
fonction qui est utilisée pour faire une
régression
il faut que j'indique ensuite la
variable qui va servir
il y donc la variable a expliqué c'est
la variable response
il faut que je tique avec méthode habs
les paramètres que je dois appliquer
la méthode pour avoir le type que je
veux moi ce que je veux faire céder
régression logistique binaire donc je
rappelais glm avec l'option familiale
binomiale donc méthode argh ça va
prendre une liste avec les arguments
qu'on doit rajouter à la méthode ici glm
donc je signe en familier galles
binomiale
et puis je vais rajouter exponentielle
égale choo
vous montre ce que ça donne
ça même
calcul 1
l'idée c'est que du coup
tibi à lui vers
l'univers y est
arrivé pour unibail y est on va calculer
un modèle courage un pur gradins pour ce
stage on qu'on fait on a un modèle qui
est quel est l'effet de hache sur aube
response qu'il ait l'effet de gouetsoule
response qui avait fait deux stages sur
response ces trois modèles non ajustées
par les autres variables dont trois
modèles univariée qui sont faits les uns
près des autres par défaut ça nous
affiche le nombre d'observations valide
et puis on a les zones ratio les
intervalle de confiance à 95 % et les
pieds valeur je pourrais si je le
voulais
cachée
avec l'option n
les
les intervalles de confiance
pendant les les valeurs du petit m ce
qu'on va avoir c'est qu'on peut s'amuser
à combiner tout ça là je vais
sauvegarder tout ça dans un tableau que
j'établis était belle unis
d'accord donc là je vais vous l'affiché
mon tableau tbl unis 1 selon du coût des
cds des modèles by variés un univers y
est c'est à dire à chaque fois c'est
l'effet c laude ratio de chacune des
variables sur les autres mais chaque
variable prix une à une
j'aurais pu faire quelque chose
d'indescriptible où j'ai fait un tableau
descriptif avec un petit billet elle se
marie donc là
dans ce cas là je vais faire je parle de
ce royaume
je fais un tb elle se marie
by response
in cloud
galles ces âges
grade stage
et puis on va fou je vais rajouter des
tests de comparaison avec 1 à 10
donc là
je fais
mon tableau ici je vous montre mon
tableau descriptif
l'a cette fois ci c'est plutôt les
pourcentages que j'affiche avec une paie
valeur de comparaison par intéresse 2000
coxon maquis tenait ou un thé du kid
enfin
je pourrais faire un modèle multi mariés
donc pour ce 1 je fais un glm qui sera
responsable
syed
2h plus crade plus stage
avec des tigers royal
et family égale binomiale
je pense un tibet l irrigation
exponentielle exponent site et un trou
et on
du coup
sûr ce troisième sur ce troisième
tableau qui lui un an sont cette fois ci
le coefficient à ajuster les uns sur les
autres puisqu'on a fait un un modèle
multi variés
et bien on peut tout mettre dans un seul
tableau si on veut me je vais faire un
tbl
merde
donc je vais qui analyse le tableau je
vais prendre mon tbl descriptif on table
au descriptif montée bl univariée et mon
tableau
multivariée
on va utiliser le tap scanner
pour l'indiquer dont classe et analyse
descriptive
modèle et variés
et un modèle
multivariée
alors les double étoiles c'est pour dire
que je veux que mes titres soit
l'affiché en grains
et si on fait ça
voyez un grand tableau mais j'ai un
compte alors je veux le zoom est
peut-être ici
mais j'aime tableau avec l'ensemble des
éléments et voyez tout est bien
fusionner en fonction des mêmes
variables donc j'ai à la fois la partie
description descriptive ici les
résultats du modèle bi variés et les
résultats du modèle multivariée
alors je faux avant de passer la suite
je vois une question mais capable est
tout à fait en lien avec notre sujet du
jour c est ce qu on peut faire un modèle
mixte tout en prenant en compte le plan
d'échantillonnage complexe avec jti se
marie comme je voulais dit vous avez
sur le site analyse un analyseur
dans statistiques d'avancé à chablis qui
s'appelle quel type de modèle choisir
qui vous présente une synthèse de
différents types de modèles
et donc je vous invite à regarder par
ici même si là la question c'est un
modèle mixte tout en prenant en compte
le plan d'échantillonnage complexe avec
getis mal juste un détail quand vous
avez un plan d'échantillonnage complet
que vous avez pas besoin de rajouter un
effet de faire un modèle mixte si vous
avez des données répéter ou d'une
édition kloster s'est pris en compte
dans votre plan d'échantillonnage
complexe dont il n'y a pas besoin
d'aller partir sur un modèle mixte
vous êtes parce que les fêtes cluster va
être pris en compte par le plan
d'échantillonnage là on aura un modèle
mixer quand on aura des données répétées
et sans prix en fait sens et on dans ce
cas là on n'aura pas besoin de prendre
en compte le plan d'échantillonnage
complexe parce que la répétition les
effets cluster seront pris en compte
dans votre modèle mixte je développe pas
plus que ça on soit c'est un sujet et
c'est une session entière mais ça nous
sort du coup l'objectif du jour qui est
de développer sur dix semaines
alors
je vais aborder comment exporter nos
résultats
avant d'aller ensuite sur des choses un
petit peu plus poussé la première chose
qu'il faut savoir c'est que
les tableaux qui sont produits par titi
se marient peuvent être rendu avec
plusieurs moteurs de tableau par défaut
ce que vous voyez ça utilise le moteur
ji t-il package éthique à la grammaire
des tableaux qui est assez avancé sur
[Musique]
qui relativement bien avancé
sur le sait ce qui aura le plus de rendu
avec les notes les types les mélanges
mais qui ne marche pas sur certaines
sorties alors ça marche pas très bien la
couleur c'est pas compatible et avec on
peut avoir des surprises
lorsque l'on fait des sorties avec
en pdf même si le support complet des
pdf est prévue c'est en cours de travaux
normalement gt devrait être compatible
prochainement avec les les les avec des
avec les pdf dc dc moins d'un an vous
avez ensuite d'autres paquets de
l'existant promettre en forme des
tableaux vous avez flexible xt ball club
avec ce froid et câbles ont chacun leurs
avantages et leurs inconvénients câble
ça fait un export qui marchera vers
toutes les sorties html pdf rtf world
mais avec certains éléments de mise en
forme qui seront perdus xt belle marche
avec tout même si c'est un petit peu
moins jolie québec j'étais
affecté bellemare bien vers pdf et vers
word et câbles extra a mal marché que
vers html et pdf vous voyez ici alors
vous avez par défaut ce que fait jean se
marie c'est que si vous êtes dans un
documentaire markdown avec une sortie
html il va prendre j'étais si vous
faites une sortie vers word il va
appliquer plutôt flexible vous pouvez
toujours forcés en fait le format de
sortie ou de rendu avec as j'étais assez
flexible à hickstead bolou asca bextra
vous voyez là c'est un roddick est pris
au format j'étais j'obtiens ceci quand
je fais mon ma sortie en site web avec
flex t ball le tableau voyait a pas tout
à fait la même forme il est déjà mis en
forme un peu différemment et
là vous avez le rendu avec externe et là
vous l'avez avec câble extra
votre rendu va dépend de ce qu'on peut
en faire pour ma part en général ce que
je fais je travaille toujours des
cheveux et des tableaux je travaille
avec les remarques town pour mes propres
analyses je vais plutôt fermé sortie en
format html et puis je vais quand j'ai
besoin je vais copier ça et que je vais
recoller dans un document word quand je
suis en train de rédiger mon l'article
final
vous êtes parce qu'il ya toujours des
petits détails que je que je refais sur
les articles finaux
vous avez aussi la possibilité de
transformer votre tableau en un petit
bol d'or avec la fonction à steven quand
on fait ça c'est que ça devient
simplement un tableau de donner le plus
basique possible donc on va perdre la
mise en forme et vous avez du coup
quelque chose qui est manipulable maxime
en os ou sous there
si on veut exporter son tableau dans un
fichier html ou dans un fichier tech
d'accord vous pouvez le transformer au
format j'étais donc vous utilisez à gt
pour forcer la transformation du tableau
en un objet j'étais grammaire of the
world il ya une fonction j'étais celle
qui permet d'exporter ensuite en html en
latex sont rtl et ça vous permet
d'enregistrer votre tableau dans un
fichier
si on veut exporter un tableau dans un
fichier word
on peut le transformer en flex s'ébranle
et appelé la fonction save as docx de
flex des bols qui va transformer votre
tableau en format docx maintenant la
question qui est posée c'était qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour exporter au format excel
et la question c'est qu'est ce qu'on
veut dire par exporter un tableau format
excel
si on veut des données brutes dans le
format excel vous transformer en un
objet dans un petit bol on n'aura que la
donnée brute ou renommés et ensuite vous
pouvez enregistrer ce t-ball qu'à un
tableau de données
au format excel ou en format csv avec
les fonctions classiques d'export de
data 7
mais vous perdez de la mise en forme est
toute la question c'est qu'est ce que
vous voulez exporter
sybille se jettent ils se marient et là
pour mettre en forme des tableaux les
cellules que vous avez le peuvent
contenir plusieurs statistiques on n'est
pas sur des données brutes
si vous voulez avoir les informations
brutes d'un tableau
il faut savoir par exemple que quand
vous avez un grand tableau descriptif
qui m'ont objets qui se marie en fait il
contient différents objets avant
transformation dont un des bols body
et qui lui va contenir les informations
de manière brute
avec différents les résultats de tests
et compagnie donc en fait la question
c'est qu'est ce que vous voulez exporter
comme on voulait exporter
mais excellent et pareillement un
formats d'export d'un tableau de
résultats mis en forme excellent est
plutôt un formats d'export de données
brutes
si vous voulez exporter malgré tout un
excellent vous passez par la stib
alors ma on a vu tout ça on va pouvoir
aborder
petite note
quelques fonctions avancées que nous
n'avons pas encore vu
dangers qui se marie on avait vu la
dernière fois comment faire des tables
hautes et tri à plat des tris croisés
avec tibi elle se marie on n'a pas
abordé
la fonction tibi elle continue
alors tibet le conti news elle
intervient dans un cas un peu
particulier c'est quand on a une
variable continue et on aimerait bien a
résumé en fonction de deux ou plusieurs
variables catégorielles supposons que ce
que j'aimerais avoir ça serait l'âge
moyen de les participants selon
traitement et selon la variable grade
oui pour ça on peut du coup avoir appel
à variable à tibi et le continue donc
j'appelais trail au tibet a continué
j'ai déjà indiqué qu'elles sont mes
lignes et colonnes comme on le ferait
avec un tibia elles se marient donc byte
rtc pour dire je veux un des colonnes en
fonction du traitement et include égale
stage grade ça va représenter mes lignes
par contre ce que je vais dire ce que je
veux représenter dans les cellules c'est
pas le pourcentage observations de stage
en fonction de traitement c'est
plutôt
une
résumé statistique d'une variable
continue donc la variable qui va
m'intéresser ici ch
je vais indiquer la statue qui a affiché
statistiques alors pareil on peut faire
des syndics différentes suivant les
lignes on va faire la même chose pour
tout le monde donc je mets rien tila ce
qui veut dire everything team et je vais
afficher
la moyenne
n'oubliez pas accolades autour de
moyenne là on est vraiment sur la même
c'est un taxes qu'on a pour d'autres et
puis je vais indiquer aussi dj tz
égal 1 pour forcer à voir partout 1
chiffres après la virgule
donc en vous en calculant ce tableau là
en fait j'affiche et statistiques de âge
ici la moyenne puisque c'est la moyenne
que je demandais j'aurais pu demander la
médialle le maximum l'écart type comme
précédemment donc je vais les
statistiques calculées sur la variable
âge qui doit être une variable continu
représentés en fonction bas de la
variable traitement et de la variable
stage et grades donc je sais que les
personnes qui sont
à l'étape t1 et qui prennent le
traitement à en 44 ans en moyenne alors
que celles qui prennent le traitement b
qui sont à l'étape tu es une ont 40 ans
25 en moyenne il est aussi possible
d'appliquer un add aux rôles pour
calculer
une colonne qui fusionne le médicament a
est
alors le havre ne marche pas ah oui il
ya eu un bug sur le adoboli il sera
corrigé après
dans la version de développement de là
il ya un petit bug sur la version
actuelle office qui se marient mais qui
corrigé dans la version de développement
ce qu'on retient c'est que tibial
continue au sein c'est pour représenter
dans mes cellules en fait je représente
la statistique d'une variable continu
que je dessine dans variable et ça me
permet de avoue après de faire en sorte
que votre site soit clair c'est âge
moyen des participants en fonction du
traitement et du niveau d'avancement de
la manette
en fait on peut aller plus loin
et pour aller plus loin il faut se
tourner vers la fonction tbl
custom
semaine
les à fond
costumes se marie elle va encore un coup
plus loin
la passe et on peut aller très loin dans
les options mais ce qui se passe c'est
que donc tu es belle que ce tome se
marie on va devoir indiquer une fonction
qui m a calculé statistiques qu'on
affiche
et je vais commencer pour vous expliquer
ça avec un premier exemple est en fait
on va on va essayer de refaire à peu
près ce qu'on vient de faire là
donc je parle de favre
je vais appeler tes mails custom son
mari donc je vais organiser un tableau
d'accord avec un bail terre tu es
include égal c'est state grid donc le
syndic en fait comment j'organise les
lignes et les colonne du tableau
sauf qu'ensuite je vais devoir un ticket
je vais devoir fournir une fonction
qui va me permettre de calculer le
contenu de mes lignes et quelques des
statistiques alors il y a soit je vais
pouvoir écrire ma propre fonction soit
je peux utiliser des fonctions qui sont
déjà fourni des haters
qui sont fournis dans jeet ils se
marient et qui renvoie en fait
directement une fonction adapté je vais
faire le premier cas de figure qui
savent avec continue où se marient
d'accord
stats effet fns c'est pour dire qu'elle
et ses paramètres que je dis c'est pour
indiquer les fonctions de calcul
comme tous les autres paramètres c'est
soit une liste avec en dix ans le pur
style je veux ça pour ma part je veux ça
donc c'est une c'est une formule où une
liste de formule donc là j'ai rentré une
formule d'accord et je vais juste me
till pour dire pour toutes les cellules
tableau pour toutes les variables qu'est
ce que je veux j'appelle continue et se
marient et je vais indiquer âge c'est
pour dire et il continue se marie en
fait deux âges ça va renvoyer une
fonction c'est comme l'histoire te faire
des labels si je stocke
dans f
ce que ça me renvoie en fait à un moment
une fonction qui va calculer des résumés
sur âge tout simplement
donc
et ça va continuer se marier pour
calculer les mêmes statistiques que
quand on que pour une variable continu
dans un tibet elles se marient classique
d'accord et ensuite faut que j'ai
indiqué c'est ici que je veux affiché il
n'y a pas de statistiques par défaut
avec ti belkacem sommelier vous a
toujours indiqué manuellement les
statistiques affichées là par exemple je
veux la moyenne
et les quartiers
loyer j'ai refait ce qu'on avait tout à
l'heure on a refait à peu près le même
graphique je peux indiquer ici un dj tz
alors tilde un pur pour forcer
normalement ici le hades aux rôles
fonctionne
si
ça fonctionne et vous avez aussi
dans les options telles que l'ensemble
se marient l'option de m halle aux
voiles ou gros égale choo pour dire je
vais vous en plus une ligne total
vous voyez ça ma rage ming total donc du
coup ça me permet de voir que l'âge
moyen est de 40 m2 an
en moyenne dans l'ensemble des
échantillons 47 ans pour ceux qui
prennent le traitement 1,47 quatre ans
pour ceux qui prennent le traitement des
ailes après vous avez le détail 1 pour
les pour les différentes dates donc la
voilà en fait aux robots c'est
l'équivalent du haut vol' colonnes et
d'anti bielle customshow mairie vous
avez aussi si vous activez un os x 1 go
pouvait indiquer sous la vallée en début
enfin avec au voile bol last vous avez
au vent nouveau label qui permet de
changer l'étiquette qu'il a et total
autres
elle peur de tibial que sam se marient
qui fournit ces propos jeunes se marient
vous avez trois lpr qui aujourd'hui
existe pour stats fns continue son mari
oui je suis au sommet lui est pourtant
une semaine si j'ouvre propose une se
marie ça permet de calculer en fait
une proportion
et on va avoir besoin qu'on lui donne la
variable sera calculé la proportion les
valeurs à prendre en compte et ça va
nous calculé
petites haines le numérateur grands
thèmes le dénominateur propre la
proportion et si jamais on a un
numérateur qui est entier ça vous fera
aussi à intervalle de confiance
de la proportion avec un flou et confus
pour l'intervalle on va reprendre un
exemple
je veux représenter 1
c'est
la proportion de personnes pour
lesquelles la variable stéitsch vos t3
je remonte à la variable stage ici
un t1
au t4 moi ce que je veux c'est la
proportion de personnes pour laquelle la
variable stage vos
t3 ou t4
comme tout on fait la construction du
tableau donc là j'ai par exemple faire
by trt
include égal stitch
non j'ai pas inclure stich puisque
c'était ce que je représente donc j'ai
pu tout faire grid
je veux indiquer donc stats
fns là je vais appeler du coup
promotion'
se marient et donc je vais indiquer que
je veux calculez proportion à partir de
la variable donc nous demande le nom de
la variable non classés stéitsch
joue indiqué là où les valeurs que je
prends donc en jeu la proportion qui
sont égales à t3 ou t4 john deux valeurs
t3 et t4
et je dois dans tous les cas indiquer
les statistiques affichées donc
statistiques
moi ce que je veux affiché c'est donc du
coup
le pourcentage et puis
les intervalles de confiance donc là
le % appel propre
et puis je vais intérêts chez ans entre
parenthèses je vais appeler qu'on flow
tiré
quand points aïe
on va déjà prêt t ce tableau là
pourquoi il est pas content
j'ai un petit souci ni
excuser moi alors tout ça vient ça
ah oui pardon comprend ici j'ai oublié
de mettre le tilde
voilà
donc
tilde d'accord donc du coup là j'ai mes
résultats alors il faut que j'en dis que
ça soit du bourg sont envoyés par défaut
les résultats sont proposés un pour cent
pour cent c'est qu'il faut que je change
aussi la mise en forme du même nom il
faut que je dise que je veux les mettre
en pourcentage donc je vais indiquer dj
train
donc je vais appliquer partout skyos
la belle paire cents pour les mettre en
pourcent et puis j'ai indiqué que je
veux un chiffre près les virgules
et là j'ai direct
alors sauf que là ça me rajoute le
chiffre % par tout ce qui est un peu
lourd je vais
modifier suffixe vide et je vais pas
mettre le pourcentage partout et puis je
l'indiqué ici uniquement pour l'affiché
donc tibia ce mal et ça permet de faire
un peu tout ce qu'on veut par contre
voyez on doit bien précise il n'y a pas
de traitement par défaut des
statistiques affichées ou de la mise en
forme des nombres il faut un peu
spécifié tout au cas par cas mais là
j'ai la proportion de personnes qui sont
t3 ou t4
dans mon échantillon et je peux comme
toujours ajouter les ados voire
la mise en forme ici en bas et pas
forcément des plus appropriés mais
je peux utiliser un modify votre note
pour
pour rendre les choses plus visible je
pourrais faire modify
footnote aux stats comme pour toutes les
colonnes de nom et là on va dire c'est
prop de thé 3h
t4
entre crochets qui c'est 95% je peux
modifier un moi-même ma note de bas de
page de tableau pour avoir quelque chose
qui soit plus plus pertinents
enfin je vous montre le le dernier lpr
de base
qui est riche et où se marient donc où
les chiots se marient lui permet de
calculer
riches
riz permet quant à lui de calculer
un ratio donc on va qu'on va additionner
une variable additionner une autre
variable et fait qu'on va appeler
numérateur et le dénominateur pour faire
le rapport entre les deux skippers
calculer un ratio ici jamais le
numérateur est un an quand y est on peut
calculer du coup un intervalle de
confiance à partir d'un test de poisson
donc là l'exemple qu'on va prendre
je vais prendre deux variables j'ai
regardé les sprints idf on va calculer
la somme de response dans chaque groupe
puis la somme de tdf dans chaque groupe
pour calculer ensuite le ratio entre les
deux types icm ans c'est ce qu'on ferait
pour faire un tableau d'incidence
donc trahi à
siby elle
thompson oui
comme toujours on indiqué une variable
un côté
include égal ce stage
vous m'aidez vraiment les vrais que vous
voulez à gauche ou à droite donc la
particularité c'est donc stats
fns le til death wish you sommellerie
donc là en fait le ratio qu'on veut
avoir c'est la variable response
l'avarié apted f
donc pour rappel plus précisément c'est
on va faire la somme des response et la
sympathie des fessées les relations
entre les deux
on va représenter statistiques
jouent indiqué t-il dit ce que je veux
représenter donc les statistiques en
fait en fait les statistiques
disponibles que l'on peut appeler ici
dans statistiques sont celles qui sont
renvoyés par la fonction qu'on
appliquait en classe elle qu'on peut
qu'on à disposition ses camps flocons
faille richier onu mais dénomme donc là
moi je vais afficher plus tôt donc
ratio
est entre en thèse nîmes /
dénomme
et puis
pour mettre en forme
tout ça a
été l'enfer dj
donc voyez là
alors ça marche pas il faut que je mette
plutôt parce que j'ai des
je vais arrondir je vais faire 0 0 sera
plus facile à lire
donc j'ai 00 12 qui correspond à 1 7 /
583 est donc là j'ai monde y est j'ai
mon ratio on peut vraiment commencer
jongler comme ça à pouvoir faire des
choses beaucoup plus avancé est là si le
résultat d'un ratio n'en voyez ici on a
un tableau qui en fonction de stages et
de trt et qui présente une statistique
acculé sur deux autres variables du
tableau initial
alors
il ya une question qui nous est posée
ici
qui est la différence entre les
accolades et des crochets dans la
syntaxe de l'argument statistiques car
effectivement je sais que ça a empiré
plus plusieurs d'entre vous
ici à
statistiques en fait il faut retenir on
passe par ce qu'on appelle une fonction
s'appelle lui gl us ou les savoir plus
sur la taxe l'idée c'est que on met
entre accolade la variable qu'on va les
remplacer les accolades c'est pour dire
la
accolade pays européens colette ça veut
dire ici je vais afficher la valeur
propre
ici
chez conf l'eau ou qu'on frei donc les
accolades si vous voyez elles
n'apparaissent
jamais dans
le résultat 1 à cologne c'est pour dire
ici je n'affiche pas le mot propre où je
mords ratio j'affiche la variable ratio
d'accord donc les accolades sont
utilisés dans ces endroits là pour
indiquer je veux remplacer cet espace à
part quelque chose qui s'appelle ratio
les parenthèses ou les crochets pour le
coup eux ils sont affichés la voyez
[Musique]
mon effectif il a affiché entre
parenthèses alors pourquoi ici j'ai
utilisé parenthèse sur ce tableau l'un
est que sur le tableau d'avant j'ai
utilisé des crochets
ça c'est un choix esthétiques j'aurais
pu décider de mettre l'intervalle de
confiance entre parenthèses et non pas
entre crochets
ça des questions d'affichage assez
souvent dans certains contextes vous
verrez qu'il ya un peu dur de code sont
les intervalles de confiance ont souvent
mis entre crochets mais c'est un code
sous jacent mais retenez bien là que
j'utilise des crochets des parenthèses
ce sont des choses qui sont affichés
dans le résultat les accolades elle par
contre elles ont un sens programmatique
puisque ici les accolades représente un
élément a remplacé donc ça peut être un
nombre variable il faut savoir ça
pourrait être aussi une fonction de
transformation en fait on peut aller
assez loin si ça vous intéresse dont
vous savoir plus je vous invite à
regarder l'aide de la fonction lui du
package du même nom
le package inclut en fait c'est
ça va assez loin c'est ce qui va
permettre de faire en fait des
transformations de mise en forme dans du
texte donc danger qui se marient retenez
c'est le nom d
c'est le nom des variables qu'on va
chercher d'accord donc ça ratio est
remplacé par
accolade ratio accolades et remplacé par
la variable à sion alors que si je ne
mets pas d'accolades vous compreniez
bien
ratio est entendu comme le texte ratio
donc
tistics et le texte que j'affiche et
j'indique entraco line les passages du
texte qui doivent être remplacés par une
valeur c'est à dire par une variable
sur tibia clinton se marie on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin et je pas forcément
prendre le ton ce soir de vous expliquer
comment est ce qu'on écrit sa propre
fonction parce que là on arrive sur des
choses qui seront peut-être un peu
compliqué pour certains d'entre vous ce
qu'il faut savoir et je vous renvoie du
coup
au chapitre tableaux statistiques
avancées avec l'outil se marie
en train de charger
petites secondes je vous présente
à
un peu plus bas dans le chapitre comment
on pouvait écrire votre propre fonction
personnalisée ses fonctions un peu un
peu plus compliqué parce qu'en fait
c'est un va lui passer à table qui va
recevoir différents arguments
et eux
et qui en fait
va calculer
elle va recevoir un sous-ensemble de
marqueurs et elle va pouvoir qualité des
statistiques et donc du coup ça peut
faire vraiment ce que vous voulez
là vous avez un exemple une fonction qui
va vous affichez la somme de marqueurs
et la moyenne d'âge est en du coup on
peut faire un tableau partout partout
qui va
afficher à chaque endroit la somme de
marqueurs à la moyenne d'âge on peut
faire des choses un peu plus complexes
par exemple comparer à une moyenne
globale
calculé différence voilà on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin
comme c'est du coup un usage qui est
plus avancée sachez que ça existe et le
jour où vous n'aurez besoin à les
creuser les exemples qui sont donnés il
ya encore moyen d'aller un peu plus loin
aussi avec la fonction at stats mais là
c'est encore un poil plus compliqué en
termes d'attraction et donc du coup ça
me semble difficile à
deux vous lui présentez aujourd'hui
parce que j'aimerais encore vous
présenter quelques petites choses
juste avant je vois qu'il ya quelques
questions qui sont pendantes
alors la question c'est est-ce que la
fonction tv elle continue peut être
utilisé pour les médianes oui on peut
calculer une médiane tibet elle continue
ce tout comme continue son mari accepte
lançant dans les paramètres des
statistiques que l'on peut afficher en
champ statistique
on peut prendre tous les éléments que
l'on utilise pour un tibet elle se marie
donc pour rappel vous pouvez quand on
fait un tibet le sommet pour une
variable continu un vous pouvez
ou est ce point là vous avez ici la
médiane la moyenne les quartiers plats
variés ans au minimum le maximum les
personnes t-il voir des fonctions
personnalisées donc en fait c'est on
peut utiliser les mêmes choses à cet
endroit là
alors autre question posée peut-on
utiliser d'élitisme relais pour faire
les tableaux de la régression multi
nominale witi bl régulation fonctionne
avec un grand nombre de modèles y
compris la régression multi nominale
d'ailleurs vous avez un bon exemple
quand on va dans le chapitre sur la
régulation logistique multi nominal
ainsi misé sur la régression logistique
multimodale vous verrez à
un exemple deux tableaux multi nauviale
qui affichait avec les jeunes ce que
fait tibial wilson c'est que pour le
modèle 1000 2000 à lille vous mais les
tableaux les uns au-dessus des autres
alors
pour tibi elle continue ou c'est ce que
l'on peut faire un tableau de
comparaison de moyenne avec variable
dépendante comme âge et avec quelques
variables indépendantes qui a été hâtive
comme sage et grades
si vous qu'on vous les comparez des
moyennes c'est pa ti bien content in
youth que vous devriez utiliser
[Musique]
pour des tableaux de comparaison de
a
si vous voulez comparer la moyenne entre
2 po poum
ça serait avec indifférence
si vous voulez comparer des moyennes
d'accord je voudrais comparer par
exemple l'âge moyen
si je veux comparer l'âge moyen entre le
traitement à et le traitement b d'accord
il me faut
vous faites un don qu'on va faire un
tibia il se marie classique pour le coup
sauf que la variable de comparaison ça
va être le traitement
la variable que je veux comparer je peux
en mettre plusieurs on va comparer l'âge
moyen est la valeur moyenne de marqueurs
d'accord et une statistique je vais
afficher pour toute la moyenne
quand je fait ce tableau l'agent
représente la moyenne 2 h pour age et
marqueurs et l'a donc là j'ai la moyenne
2 h pour le traitement à la moyenne 2 h
pour le traitement des la moyenne de
marqueurs pour le traitement et la
moyenne de marqueurs pour le traitement
b et vu que là je compare que deux
groupes je peux rajouter un add
différence
et j'ai la différence entre mes deux
groupes l'intervalle de confiance de la
différence et la paix valeur de la
différence
tibi elle continue news c'est quand on
représente une troisième variable en
fonction d'une autre variable
si par contre vous aviez besoin de faire
ceci
pour
je ne sais pas moi le grade 1 le grade
de le cracker vous vouliez comparer la
différence d'âge entre a et b pour le
grade 1 puis la différence d'âge entre a
et b pour
le grade depuis pour le crac trois
forêts jongler avec un tibia strata on a
vu précédemment plus votre cible ils se
marient ici
alors il ya ça petites choses que je
vous ai pas encore présenté et que
j'aimerais présenter rapidement pour
vous pour ou sachez que ça puisse
exister
notamment tu es belle sophie
trouve une petite note
donc tibet elle se fit
est utilisé
lorsqu'on fait de l'analyse de survie
ont fait des coupes de caplan mayer donc
on avait abordé sa dans un chapitre
dédié
pour faire un cap man manière rapide si
vous vous le souvenir plus que ça qu'un
kaplan meier oublier ce passage là elle
est d'abord revoir le cours sur
l'analyse de survie mais
je suppose qu'on fasse un cap lo manière
assez simple pour rappel ça se fait avec
la fonction survival
donc je vais faire mon cap le meilleur
avec du coup
c'est la fonction surv fit qui sert à
calculer un camion mayer et
être chef
jeff
en fonction deux tiers tech
il faut que l'indiquent les données du
vol
alors j'ai vous les hanter quand même on
va je vais vous présenter un ce que
c'est que mon groupe de caplan mayer
pour rappel surv c'est la fonction gg
sauf pelote deux soeurs myners qui est
le plus simple pour représenter une
courbe de kaplan meier
donc votre courbe de kaplan meier qui
est calculé et l'indic au cours du temps
la probabilité de survie l'échantillon
chacun des deux groupes donc forcément à
zéro on est à 100% et puis cette
probabilité épaisse au cours du temps
et souvent ce qu'on aimerait ça serait
connaître et qui fait la valeur de la
probabilité à certains pas longtemps à
six mois par exemple combien il reste de
gens dans groupe à et dans le groupe b à
12 mois ou bien ce qu'il en reste donc
pour ça on peut avoir recours à la
fonction
tbl ça fait d'accord on applique un
objet d'aucun plan mayer je prends de
naujac appelant d'ailleurs je lui
applique t belle-soeur fit et je vais
indiquer des moments donc là j'aimerais
avoir la situation à zéro tant 0 autant
6 autant 12
d'accord donc à m 0 m6 à m 12 donc là ça
s'appelle
dans zéro temps 6 parce qu'on est sur le
quelque chose de génériques mais je peux
je peux dire que mais il en tête de
colonne
je peux les analyse et donc la balle
leader égales
- et entre crochets tarim à la valeur de
la varde times à ce moment là
donc ce qu'on voit c'est que à 0
forcément si je remets mon graphique
d'avant on est toujours à 100 % à 6 mois
on est à 99 % dans groupe a et donc
groupe b
est ce que vous avez même c'est les
intervalles de confiance 1 95% 82 7 % et
100 % et au mois 12 on est à 80% et à
86%
si je regarde l'aide de tibial sur fit
vous verrez qu'on a un paramètre
statistiques et que par des fossés
estimé qu'on flocons ferraille qui sont
représentés mais vous pouvez du coût
adapté malgré tout ce qui représente
hermes et les éléments qu'on a de base
et vous avez quand le fleuve elle pour
paramétrer le niveau de confidences
une autre manière parfois de regarder un
tableau de survie
mettre le graphique c'est de savoir plus
tôt au lieu de regarder à un certain
temps quel pourcentage et atteint
parfois qu'on cherche c'est qu'elle ait
le temps pour atteindre un certain
niveau par exemple à quel au bout de
combien de temps il ne reste plus que 50
% l'échantillon c'est le temps médian
pour le coup
donc on pourrait regarder à quel me
combien de temps il faut pour atteindre
60 50 % de l'échantillon
est donc au lieu de donner à
la tva ça fit
une série de temps
on peut lui donner plus tôt
une série
[Musique]
une série de
dérivés
une série voilà deux de niveau de
probabilité de pour la pour la survie
parmi combien de temps il faut pour
atteindre 60 pour qu'ils aient plus que
75 % de l'échantillon combien de temps
pour 50% combien de temps pour 25% donc
on peut indiquer plutôt des probabilités
avec le paramètre
props par exemple ou revoir le temps
nécessaire qu'il y ait plus de 75% de
survivants 50% ou 25%
vous avez le temps pour que ce soit
vécue alors en fait ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que le pour-cent t-il ici
c'est parce que pour sent-il de
personnes qui ont vécu ces pour son
style de personnes de par ces deux
personnes encore en vie mais plutôt de
ceux qui ont déjà vécu l'événement donc
j'ai inversé un tout petit peu rendre ça
plus lisible donc c'est à dire que pour
que ce 25 % de l'échantillon
est vécu l'événement si je reviens sur
mon graphique 1 25% a vécu l'événement
c'est à dire que 75 % ne l'ont pas
encore vécu
un donc 25 % de gens qui ont vécu
l'événement c'est à dire que 75% sont
toujours en vie salaires n'ont toujours
pas vécu l'événement et donc voilà je
l'a 75 % il me faut ce temps là pour
regrouper et se tourne là pour le groupe
à et plus précisément en fait il faut
dix sept mois pour le groupe à 15 mois
pour le groupe b la médiane est atteint
au bout de 21 mois dans le groupe b et
24 - le groupe a et on voit que le
troisième pour säntis et 25% n'est pas
atteint dans graphique et c'est pour ça
que j'ai des valeurs manquantes qui sont
affichées
donc ça un élément donc c'est un élément
à retenir tu es belle soeur fit va vous
permettre de représenter vos résultats
sachez aussi que tu es belle soeur foot
on peut lui aller un peu plus loin et
faire des tableaux un peu plus poussés
par exemple en lui passant une une série
de
à une série en fait de kaplan meier
je vais vous montrer un exemple rapide
mais si vous faisiez un kaplan meier
générique puis des capelans wire par
différentes variables
vous pouvez
les passés ensemble pour arriver à
présenter ben effet total bien et fait
part pour le traitement et au paraguay
donc voilà on a moyen de faire des
choses un peu plus poussée et si vous
faites du multivariée n'oubliez pas le
modèle de cox fonctionne aussi avec tvl
et je me permets
tout
juste pour vous montrer c'est un peu le
cadeau bonux à de cette fin d'année
puisque c'est bientôt noël pour
présenter rapidement billets stephen
alors bis et stephen c'est un peu une
petite soeur de jean marie c'est un
package qui est développée aussi par
daniel sjoberg mais qui n'est pas sur le
cran c'est un package est un peu
expérimentale où on ya plusieurs
fonctions qui sont mises dedans on peut
les tester voir comment ça marche et
puis le cas échéant si l'on pense que la
fonction les vraiment pertinente on peut
déplacer la fonction dans
dans danger ti samarie donc
particularité s'installe pas bien le
cran de manière traditionnelle il faut
du coup installé depuis kitab vous avez
ici la commande par contre pour pouvoir
faire ça sourit une dose il faut vous
ayez aussi installé un package qui
s'appelle un outil qui s'appelle faire
tout ce qui est disponible là et je
voulais juste vous montrer quelques
éléments une fonction qu en cours
développement que c'est un package de
belles les cartes en sciences sociales
vous avez souvent je pense d'années de
type échelle l'opinion par exemple et
donc vous avez plusieurs fonctions
variable qui ont les mêmes modalités
in on ne sait pas ou plutôt d'accord
complètement d'accord plutôt d'accord
nida core n'y ait pas d'accord plutôt
pas d'accord complètement pas d'accord
ce genre d celle là et vous avez du coup
six ou sept que variable ou question à
qui on pose ça et puis vous avez la
réponse pour chacun d'eux donc quand on
présente la jour prend dé donner
d'exemples qu'on avait utilisé pour des
graphiques avancées vous êtes plusieurs
questions qui sont codées en wind on ne
sait pas
et si on fait un tibet elle se marie
avec ses ouïes variable voyez ça me fait
première question oui non ne s'est pas
deuxième question oui non ne sais pas
troisième question donc c'est ça fait un
gros tableau c'est pas forcément lisible
comme les modalités de réponse sont les
mêmes pour les différentes variables on
pourra représenter ça de manière un peu
plus agréable et c'est ce que proposent
ces belles lichens qui en cours
d'expérimentation et simplement vous
voyez j'ai toutes mes questions et les
modalités sont présentés ici en colonne
pour avoir quelque chose de plus facile
à lien sachez que ça existe je pense que
tu es belle lichens intégrerait un jour
donc immo dans un an 10,6 et marie mai
qui reste voilà pour le moment c'est
encore expérimental dans des choses un
peu expérimentale vous avez aussi
hâte sparkline qui permet de rajouter
dans un pays si j'ai une variable à je
l'avais marqueur de rajouter un petit
graphique directement dans mon tableau
vous avez aussi add in line with claude
qui dans un résultat très belle rigolait
elle permet de rajouter en fait dans le
tableau directement un mini forrest
pelote 1 plutôt que d'avoir un graphique
des forêts ce peloton fait un mini
graphique dans le tableau et puis vous
avez assuré splot qui plutôt que de
passer par ggf modèle passe par un autre
package qui s'appelle for his pelote
pour représenter les choses aussi voilà
ça fait partie de petites choses qui
sont en plus d'en bas et stephen sachez
que ça existe surtout sachez que jean
marie il est en constante évolution
beaucoup des choses que je vous ai
présenté aujourd'hui n'existaient pas il
ya six mois ou un an dangers qui se
marient et que ça va probablement encore
s'améliorer donc vous n'êtes pas besoin
de tout maîtriser dans british mari ça
se maîtrise au fur et à mesure mais
c'est vrai que ça devient un package un
peu centrale quand on fait de la
statistiques descriptives avec r
donc prenez le temps de revoir ce
webinaire prenez le temps de retrouver
aussi de retourner sur le chapitre dédié
puisque le chapitre jetty smaoui sur
analysez vous pouvez retrouver en fait
progressivement les différentes options
ou plat
et donc d'aller voir au fur et à mesure
sachez retourné il n'y a pas besoin de
tout connaître par coeur il faut juste
savoir qu'
on peut retrouver
alors je vois qu'il ya une question
c'est est-ce que vous allez intégrer une
présentation avec gigi galli pour les
régressions non j'ai pas prévu de faire
un webinaire là dessus puisque en fait
le package et gally vous est présentée
dans le webinaire sur les rives et /
logistique on en a fait 2-2 webinaire et
ça s'est présenté sur
ces essais présentés du coude en
chapitres régression logistique pour
mieux connaître
les gg coeff pelote je vous invite à
aller soit voir les webinaires 6 et 7
qui sont donc les deux webinaire sur la
régulation logistique ne pas hésité non
plus à aller voir dans le chapitre sur
la question le site binaire où vous
représente
gg coeff modèle
un peu plus bas il est ou
représentation graphique du modèle et
puis si vous voulez connaître toutes les
options possibles avec gégé coeff modèle
donc comme beaucoup de package beaucoup
de paquets dont un site de documentation
le plus simple c'est d'abord de chercher
de pâques est toujours le cran qui est
le répertoire des package
[Musique]
de est donc si je vais sur la page gg
galy sur le cran j'ai une présentation
générale
du package et vous avez notamment le
site web du package
et si je vais sur le site web du package
dans les articles vous enverrez un il ya
rien l'article qui étaient dix à gg
coeff modèle a envoyé à deux gg coeff il
ya un premier juge et coeff il ya un
gecko les modèles g co avait en fait été
une première version qui est assez
ancienne
dont qui vous est présenté là et qu'ils
étaient garantis cipg koleff modèle et
j'ai connu une sorte d' amélioration de
gégé coeff et donc vous avez il vous est
présentée ici
allez on vous présente plusieurs des
paramètres et des options kg collecte
modèle
comment est ce qu'on peut
personnalisez certains des éléments
noter que dans gg collègues vous avez un
gg coeff multi nomme pour les modèles
multi nos maillots
[Musique]
ici et puis à
on peut aussi comparer différents
modèles alors une question ici qui était
à vous voulez savoir si on allait
intégrer une plantation de régression
que pas été jugée galy dans la fonction
à d'inline
c'est en fait c'est pas vraiment le but
de la fonction
al had in line
[Musique]
le principe de gégé galy
haute forêt splot d'ailleurs quand on
revient sur le la partie de laëtitia
mais lui ce sont avant tout de faire des
graphiques donc ces graphiques là ils
sont en propre on peut
passer notre modèle à gg coeff modèle
directement ou appliquer un blog sur
résultats tb navigation pour générer un
graphique en tant que tel
la particularité de
du 2 add in line forêt splot d'accord en
fait c'est qu'on passera encore par un
autre package pour faire un mini
graphique mais il n'y a pas là en fait
qu'on a comme objet c'est un tableau
qu'en fait ça génère un mini graphique
dans chacune de ces cases l'un
est donc a pas d'option de paramétrage
de dire je veux du l'italie du jaune en
fait on est sur autre chose donc en fait
c'est vraiment c'est soit faire un mini
forrest pelote dans un tableau qui est
avant tout un tableau qui personne au
tableau soit vous faites vraiment un
faux respecte en tant que tel avec gégé
coeff modèle et asseoir explose c'est
juste un autre package qui fait des
forêts splot donc là on crée un peu le
lien mais avec un peu une autre
philosophie que celle de gecko et ce
modèle et qui présente les choses aussi
un petit peu différemment et on n'a pas
les mêmes possibilités
vous n'avez pas à les crises et en font
donc c'est à vous de choisir l'outil le
plus adapté à un moment donné
voilà
j'espère cain que
eh bien cette présentation en deux
sessions
de
jti c'est marie vous aurait été utile
c'est aujourd'hui pour moi un des
package que j'utilise le plus angie this
summer is et
plus je le découvre et plus j'en vois
ses possibilités
ça fait partie avec deux tailles
diverses des choses qui sont vraiment
utiles au quotidien
et je trouve et qui permettent de
faciliter et présenter le résultat de
manière beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
avancé dans tous les cas je sais pas
quand est-ce qu'on aura lieu le prochain
webinaire aura lieu dans courant du
début d'année prochaine
j'aimerais à l'occasion d'aborder des
sujets un peu plus compliqué et
notamment je vous en ai pas aujourd'hui
la question des contrastes dans les
modèles quoi qu'il en soit je vous
souhaite à tous de très très bonnes
fêtes surtout reposé vous n'hésitez pas
à voir et revoir les webinaires est
retourné sur un analyseur il n'y a pas
besoin de savoir tout par coeur ce qui
est important c'est de savoir où aller
trouver l'information quand on en a
besoin et des fonctions qui sont
peut-être trop avancé pour vous
aujourd'hui c'est juste savoir qu'elle
existe pour pouvoir y retourner le jour
vous en aurez besoin dans tous les cas
je vous souhaite une une très très bonne
fin d'année et puis j'espère vous
retrouver bientôt pour un nouveau oui
binaire prenez soin de vous au revoir